all right thanks rachel and mitch um
really appreciate you having me here to
speak today i've been a big fan of r for
r and r studio for probably like a
decade now so um and and been involved
in sports analytics for longer than that
so excited to come talk about um a
couple things related to both sports
analytics
r
and google cloud where i currently work
so let me share my screen
okay make sure everyone can see it
looks good
all right
so yeah we're going to talk about
scaling sports analytics with r and
google cloud um like i said i'm alwa
patani i work as a data science
developer advocate at google cloud which
means that i
talk about how to external people
outside of the company how to use google
cloud for data science and often i like
to do that
using sports as an example because i
come from a sports background and sports
is fun and is gives us a way to talk
about um
cloud technology and data science in uh
in unique ways that um
that appeals to a large you know section
of sports fans so
a little bit of background on myself i
went to boston university
did um majored in statistics there
that's probably where i first got
started with r
very very uh different than now given
that this was um
probably more than 15 years ago now i
was fortunate to work in espn stats
information group
and was a founding member of the sports
analytics team
where we created metrics like the total
quarterback rating for the nfl and
college football as well as power
indices for various sports i'll talk a
little bit about that today depending on
where we go
um yeah it was it was great experience
there
moved on to google in 2016
and since about three years ago i've
been in the current position i'm at
google cloud where as i said i talk
about how to use google cloud tools for
data science and have worked on our
sports partnerships
initially with the ncaa
as well recently with major league
baseball golden state warriors and a few
others
a few other sort of sports related
engagements i also do other outside of
google i do some sports and data science
consulting
including for an nfl team but not the
one that won on sunday so i still have a
lot of work to do to catch up to mitch
um okay so let's
take a step back so i want to dive into
an example here but first kind of set
the background for some of the tools and
technologies i'm going to talk about
we'll dive into example look at some
code
um and then um come back and and kind of
go in some other learning at the end
hopefully we'll have plenty of time for
questions so look forward to hearing
from y'all then too
so r and bigquery for data science
so here is um
a chart that my teammate priyanka put
out recently about all the different
tools on google cloud for data science
um and you can see there's a lot right
quite frankly so if depending on how
wide your definition of data science is
and here we picked a pretty wide one
there are lots of different categories
of activities that fall into data
science
so you can see here we have things like
data engineering
right so all the all the aspects of
getting data in ingestion pre-processing
storage et cetera data analysis which is
fairly common something that a lot of
people using r will do too is
exploratory data whether you're getting
stuff you know maybe you go right from
there into an activation in a dashboard
tool
or you want to go build a model and
depending on how you want to build a
model and how
large and and sophisticated and um
and sort of what the goal of that model
is there's a ton of tools here you may
want to use
and then once you sort of have your
model it's up and running now you're
sort of in the software engineering
space where you want to manage your
model and and
all the endpoints this is where uh
certainly from my background statistics
this is new to me you end up having to
learn a bunch of technology just about
um what to do once you've kind of done
what i would consider the statistical
work and then finally kind of the most
important end goal is these activation
points um you're not doing data analysis
data science in a vacuum usually you're
trying to influence some sort of
business decision or it'll go into an
application right your your model will
be part of a software that that sort of
dictates how your business uh that then
that will be integrated into your
business i should say
so um i could spend the next uh several
hours deep diving into these pro
products i'm not not going to do that
i'm only going to talk about um probably
one of them and then maybe mention some
others as we as we go so the goal but
here the big idea is we can turn data
into insights right um faster and easier
with tools like these various ones
the one product
i do want to talk about is bigquery
so google cloud bigquery is a serverless
highly scalable and cost effective data
warehouse we have many customers using
this up that you store up up to 100 plus
petabytes of data right so that's well
larger than any of the data we're going
to talk about today but is
starting to become pretty common in the
enterprise space right where companies
have more and more data um so it's
sql-based uh you know highly available
data warehouse
some of the unique things it has is the
ability to go multi-cloud so you can
query stuff that's on google cloud
within bigquery itself but also in other
clouds
um
with a product called bigquery omni um
there's also real-time insights so based
on streaming data into google cloud with
other tools you can
set up dashboards or
other sort of interfaces where the data
coming into your warehouse is available
to you very very quickly
there's also built-in machine learning
so
through a
product called bigquery ml bigquery
machine learning you can fit a growing
number of models including linear
regression logistic regression onto
neural networks
um things that statistical r users might
be interested in too preprocessing and
that's a really nice tool for when you
have really huge data already in
bigquery you can do the machine learning
right on that data you don't have to
move it around um and then insights for
everyone um product products like bi
engine allow you to
kind of scale the way you take bigquery
and build outputs on top of it
um so this is one of my my favorite
products this was kind of came out of
work that google was doing obviously
google's huge data company the whole
concept of google cloud is taking the
infrastructure that powers things like
google search like youtube and making
that available for other businesses
okay so now let's get a little bit into
this as far as um
r and bigquery
so
i like r and i like bigquery so this
isn't uh you know what which one is
better for what you can do a lot of
things in both of them and a lot of that
will be based on sort of the use case
when i go through the example you'll see
how i'm kind of weaving between the two
but in general things i like to do in r
include getting data from lots of
different packages we'll see on here
websites apis i think the ecosystem
around how to get data into r has been
really awesome and getting better over
the last several years
general data manipulation obviously the
tidy verse is quite amazing for this i
use it
all the time extensively
and yeah i can't recommend that part
enough um
exploratory data analysis
you know whether that's
just kind of looking at your data or
plotting it with ggplot2 something like
that statistical analysis and modeling
this is where i think r has a large
depth of packages right depending on
where your background is what type of
specific model you want you can almost
always find an r package or multiple
that are doing that are available to
solve your problem and then what i call
ad hoc data visualization as i'm going i
want to look at something
quickly build a plot quickly maybe facet
the plot by a couple different
dimensions or
look at a few things as i'm doing
analysis are i think really stands out
for that bigquery like we said
enterprise data warehouse so if you want
a bunch of data that is now available
for r but maybe lots of other things
that's like the place where
we want that where uh we want that data
to be um stored
and then um and we'll look into this a
little bit too what i call intermediate
pieces some views stored procedures
often you'll have a data warehouse with
like some some very um
i guess basic foundational tables but
then on top of that you want to create
some more interesting outputs that then
maybe feed multiple other analyses right
so we'll talk a little bit about this
too
and then we talked a little bit about
bigquery ml so bigquery also can do
modeling which is um
a differentiating feature for a data
warehouse and like i said i like using
that when you have really big data
already in bigquery
and the
um storing we also like we i talked
about you can store the results in
bigquery of an analysis right not just
the base sort of data the results and
then build sort of interactive
dashboards or other data products off of
them
uh as well and then the thing at the
bottom maybe one thing that like if you
want to take away maybe you've already
if you're not using this but if you are
using r and maybe you're interested in
bigquery the big r query package is
really
um is a really strong way to integrate
the two um so you want to get data from
bigquery into r you want to take data
from r into bigquery i use this package
all the time to do this sort of stuff
thanks to
jenny bryan and hadley at the r studio
team i believe they're the developers
and maintainers of that package
okay so let's dive into an example
analysis here
um where we're going to use ncaa
basketball data march madness not too
far
around the corner
um and i have um interesting college
basketball data going back to
i don't know probably when i was kid but
also from espn where i i worked on the
original version of our basketball power
index which launched about uh almost 10
years ago to the day so i thought it
would be a cool way to
get into the idea of using r and
bigquery together and see what we can
learn about ncaa basketball
so first i'll set up the problem and
then
assuming i know how to switch my screen
i'll share other
aspects of uh share some r code as well
as bitcoin
so here's what we want to do today
um which is to create a rating system
for ncaa basketball players
so this is
um not novel tons of people
have done this type of things creating
rating systems a player rating system is
uh among one of the top sort of topics
in sports analytics
but the um
the difference here is that we want a
couple different
things to be true about this system
so we want to use
multiple player box for statistics so
for example we don't want to just take
the player who scored the most points
and say that's the best and something
like that right there's many ways that
people can contribute to the game um in
the world of the mba there's actually
way more interesting
statistics now that take into account um
sort of play-by-play level who's on the
court
um all the way to the new the newer
tracking data to do this but we're going
to assume we have more limited data but
still still very good on the player box
score level we want to take all of that
into account or as much as we can and
the second point
is important as well we want to
represent it as the player's
contribution to winning so we let's say
we had really detailed data we could say
who jumps the highest that would be a
way to rate players but it doesn't
necessarily in and of itself contribute
to winning
um so we want to take into account
statistics but also have some
relationship with winnie um the third
point is is
is important as well so often i've seen
a lot of rating system for men's college
basketball not quite as many for women's
college basketball though i think it's
growing over time we want a rating
system that can be equally applicable to
both um many statistics are collected on
on on sort of both levels let's see
again we want to talk about scaling can
we take the same system
and adapt it for uh i shouldn't say
adapter from one to the other can we
take the same system and create it for
men's and women's basketball
and then we want to apply it to the
current system but again this is about
scale we want to compare to
players in past years as well so let's
apply it to the few past years and then
this last point
which is really important
we want to adjust for schedule we don't
want to um
just take into account stats as they are
we know that in division one college
basketball there are over 350 teams each
men's and women's and teams play varying
schedules all different sorts of quality
we want to adjust for who not just um
you know
we want to account for not just what you
did but who you did it against and
that's really important so
um so why is this why would this be
important or useful so there's there's
like some
basis like people say that all-in-one
ratings are dangerous and shouldn't be
sort of consumed um and there definitely
are reasons why you don't want them
particularly in in certain instances
where you you can you want to learn more
about a player especially if you're
coaching the players on your team you
want to talk more about what that player
players strengths are how
they fit in with the rest of the team
it's not just an overall value thing but
let me take the other side and talk
about why they really are useful
sometimes so for media and fans right a
lot of a lot of people in college
basketball otherwise always talk about
who's the best player who should make a
certain team who should be an
all-american who should win the awards
and these all-in-one ratings are really
useful for that right because one player
may be really good on defense one's good
on offense one scores more one rebounds
more how do we know right and these
metrics give us a really good baseline
for some of those discussions as well as
research right so you may be watching a
game or in your media you need to call a
game college basketball again 350 plus
teams
on either side so that's thousands of
players each year the players change out
often right because they're they're
moving through especially some of the
best players go right on to the pros so
um just having an idea of who are the
best players on certain teams it can be
really useful
um so that's that's one use case and
again i in time my time at espn like
this is a lot of reason why we would
develop these player ratings
um college teams right would find this
useful for managing their own roster as
well as looking at the opponents who are
the best players on those teams
um content companies so i'm thinking
more here like even
um sort of the
companies getting into daily fantasy or
more coverage of gambling in sports
um up to something even a company like
google like if you have an all-in-one
rating what could you do with that you
might use it to figure out signals for
which players might be interesting what
keep players or people looking for
content for above and beyond how good
they kind of are to winning it's just a
measure of how interesting they are it
could be a signal in a machine learning
model right
and then finally we're talking about
college ratings the pro teams may find
these ratings interesting because they
want to evaluate again it could be nba
it could be wnbi evaluating the college
players as potential draw crash
prospects
and along with many other things right
measurables and sort of how they do in
interviews and things you might want to
use these all in one sort of ratings
okay
so this is the one
one sort of high level overview about
what we're going to do i'm going to try
to at least walk through this i won't
say fully demo this i'm gonna try to
walk through this as much as we can but
high level
we're going to use open source r
packages which exists thankfully to pull
in ncaa basketball data
and then we're going to upload it to
bigquery kind of create our mini data
warehouse
and then
instead of sort of reinventing the wheel
we're going to use existing basketball
analytics theory for how to kind of
take player stats and create a measure
of how much they impact their teams
winning and we're going to apply that in
bigquery
we're going to read that data back into
r
for our schedule adjustment
and then since it's there we're going to
calculate some stuff there and get some
final
player ratings
and it'll push it back into bigquery and
then once we start looking at them there
we'll do
the whole purpose of player ratings
which is for argument is from debate so
we'll say well this player is ranked too
highest players rank too low
and uh to some degree that at least once
i got comfortable with that i took
things uh i found it more interesting
like it no one's going to take your
playwriting system and say oh this is
perfect and it and they shouldn't and
you shouldn't either
so it's just a it's a good baseline for
a lot of the reasons we discussed and
then you go from there
okay
so let's go through the setup here
so normally i don't include
code directly on the slide at least like
this but
um i really want to point out how
awesome sort of the ecosystem is here so
i have major thanks just at the bottom
to uh sign gilani
um so he
he sort of is leader of this initiative
around the sports dataverse and has been
a developer on many packages to
kind of make sports data accessible in r
as well as python and others but we're
focusing on our today so the two you see
here hoop r and we hoop
one of them allows you
access to men's basketball data and
another as you might imagine women's
muscle data
and this is the full code to get a bunch
of data for um the history
of what's available in this package
for men's and women's college basketball
so it's about
almost 20 years but you know not as
complete here and 15 for women
and you can get teams schedule team box
player box just by
running these very well named functions
load the schedule load box
and the other good thing so again this
in uh you know times where we're working
in environment this will it will not be
this easy right go getting your data is
a
days weeks process this was not the case
in this so uh again major thanks to
simon for setting up these packages
others who have contributed as well
you can get all the data here and the
other good thing about this is that the
men's women's data comes in with the
same schema so now when we talk about
scaling
one thing we can do is actually store
them together add an extra field that
says this is men's basketball this is
women's and then every calculation we do
we can group by that sport category
and everything else kind of can flow
along and we don't have to create uh two
separate code you know cis code bases or
whatever for rating these players
okay
this might be the most
complicated slide um not sure
so
the other thing is like i said we want
to build on foundations that others have
built
for how to measure basketball players so
the framework i use here is actually
fairly
old at least old as
relative to sports analytics goes so
this is based on using box core
statistics again if you have
play-by-play you have more detailed
tracking data you can do plenty of other
things but this we have boxword data
going back you know about a decade or so
for both for both men's and women's
thanks to the the who bar and we hoop
packages
so let's let's do our best to use that
and add some of our own twists to it too
so you have player box score stats you
have team box for stats
um there's a whole lot of math developed
by dean oliver who i was fortunate
enough to work with at espn and is a
pioneer in the basketball united space
currently works as a coach for the
wizards he wrote this book basketball on
paper and did a bunch of stuff to show
how you can get the most usage out of it
to create these individual player
offensive and defensive ratings or
rating derating
um if you're familiar with basketball
analytics there's a concept called
offensive and defensive efficiency
points for 100 possessions
these are the individual analogs to
those it's not the same as what the team
does when the player is on the court
it's a much more detailed calculation
certainly on the offensive side using
points assists relative to the team and
and how well the team did overall but
um taking account the players sort of
credit for each of those things the
offensive one is much more detailed and
useful than the defensive one because
box score is traditionally very
offensive based
but you know you can calculate those
things you can calculate how many
possessions offensive player used as
well as how many defensive positions
they were involved in
um and then with that and some other
stats on league again i'm i'm hand
waving a bunch on these green big green
arrows but sports reference
among others has a wind chairs
calculation so they've detailed it here
um i hope to share these slides
afterwards you all can click the links
and everything but you can take those
metrics and then
do a bunch more math and develop these
uh calculations for offensive and
defensive wind shares
which then you can do another
calculation just add
addition so i didn't put a green arrow
here to get total wind shares um and
then i have this other adjustment here
that i
have seen and like which is to for
college basketball in particular wind
chairs has a low baseline
everyone gets kind of wins relative to
the team but when i'm more interested in
how many wins is the player at above
sort of the average division one player
whether that be men's or women's
so that's the final sort of
piece here so again a lot of pieces i'm
glossing over not going to go over this
in
in detail but you can get the idea that
we take
player and team box score stats and end
up with some metric about how
how player contributes to his or her
team's winnings
all right let's go into some code
so i'm going to
switch the sharing if i can
to
yeah
okay
all right so hopefully you can see my
our studio yeah looks good
great um so i have
this first script which is the data
gathering script i won't go into too
much
um detail again just look at the
packages we got hootbar we got we hoop
we have big r query which i talked about
that versatile package to interface
with our bigquery
i'm not going to run this right now i'm
just going to show you it takes not that
long to run maybe a few minutes again it
gathers
a large history of men's and women's
called basketball data
authenticating bigquery you can use
email authentication which i'm doing
here because i'm on the sort of like my
own laptop but um if you're doing this
on a virtual machine or somewhere you
want to use a service account and go
into that another time
bigquery has concept data sets i'll get
into in a second and who wrote this
little helper function to upload the
table into bigquery using some of the
functionality in the big r query package
this little section here is the one i
had copied this is how you read in all
the data like i said relatively
easy
um thankful to the community for
developing that the rest of this is a
bunch of just data munching
um cleaning stuff up separating out
field goals these sorts of things
um as anyone who's worked with data
knows you do have to still do some some
work to to get it in the form you want
to sort in the database especially so
this is kind of a bunch of that and then
every every um
set of data at the end we have this
little upload and replace table in
bigquery that little helper function and
that will take for example this team's
data and push it to a table in bigquery
called in this case teams
um
so yeah like i said this gets you into
bigquery which i will share now
okay
you see my screen
with google cloud platform yes all right
thanks rachel so
now we're here in google cloud um so i
think our studio should be familiar to a
lot of people here probably while you're
in the meetup google cloud may not be so
i'll go over a little bit
um of stuff here there's more way more
than i can cover in a small session but
google cloud platform
this little
um logo is bigquery so you can see we're
in the bigquery sql workspace
and here you can see what's called a
project right so i'm in this data
science demo project
and then uh data set
in this case i created one called ncaa
basketball and within my data set can be
many different things um so most
prominently we have tables which are
these ones with the sort of dark
calculator like thing and then this
these are views
we can also have models here functions
which you'll see routines
all sorts of different things
materialized views stored procedures
um but yeah so this this is kind of a
way to capsulate like a group of objects
that will relate to the same thing so
this stage called basketball data
and then what we'll look at is the
tables we created
from that r script into bigquery so we
have a table for teams
we have a table um and we can look here
so it's about
700 plus teams that's men's and women's
we have players table
so we pop that over we look at the
details you can see there's
quite quite a number of players in here
um almost 90 000 again men's and women's
going back several years
and then we created tables called
team game box to this again we want
those box score statistics for teams you
can see this has the schema down here
it's fairly wide lots of different team
statistics field goals
rebounds all the way to points
and some information about the team and
the opponent in the game this one has
like 250 000 rows 73 megabytes so again
bigquery is built for data way way
bigger than this but just to give you an
example of what
um we have in this case
and then player game box which is our
biggest table you can see here maybe
half a gigabyte and about 2.5 million
rows so yes you could process all this
in r in fact we did to get it here but
if you want to use this for multiple
things you probably want to store it in
a in some sort of database i think
bigquery is one of one option that's
pretty solid for that
and then um you can imagine running a
script the same script we have or some
other job daily to update your data
warehouse with the freshest data
as you go about there
um and then i want to go on to sort of
views
and
um
just how how much you can actually use
sql to do these calculations like i said
it's a bunch of math but it's a lot of
joining different data amongst the teams
and the players and things like that
um so you can take your team boxcord
data and
kind of augment it in this type of way i
have this view so this is a view which
means sort of uh you write a sql query
and then it stores that
sort of intermediate output so then you
can call the view as if it's its own
table so again if you have something
where you want to um there's a sim
there's a way you sort of pre-process
data all the time maybe you want to use
it and if your teammates want to use it
you may use it for one thing then you
can kind of abstract that into view this
is something coming in a lot of
databases and i think is a really useful
concept
so this view if we click over to the
details you'll see
is
really wrong and again i won't go into
code but it takes some team and game
statistics and calculates advanced stats
sort of basketball analytics 101 stats
offensive efficiency defensive
efficiency some of the four factors so
this is a useful
thing that um
i you know i can see using for multiple
things in this case we'll use it as a
stepping stone to the player ratings
and then we have another view called
player team game stats
this one again if you go over to this
details tab you can see the code behind
the view
like i said it's heavily based here on
basketball on paper and you this one is
really really really really really long
so
again not going to go totally in depth
but the last
steps are we calculate those individual
offensive ratings and defensive ratings
um the one thing i should mention
actually is this width statement for
what's called common table expressions
this i almost use like r where you're um
you know the pipe or
using different data frames and then
merging them together with the with
statement you can essentially chain
logic together so i have this team game
stack stack alex and i have player game
stack calyx right so i do some
calculations on the team level i do some
on the player level
go down here and finally we merge them
together team and player
and then you can just keep building on
your outputs so one large script is a
little more readable with these common
table expressions and allows you to
reuse pieces over and over
um
yeah and then
um
we can build a view on a view on a view
so then the last view here is one called
player season advanced stats
and i won't even show you the details
but the point is at the end here we have
this schema where we get these
calculations for wind shares and like i
said this winds above average
type of
metric
so
to some degree we might have answered
the question right here all the way in
bigquery
um and
i'm gonna see if i can
[Music]
yep so you can save your queries here so
i saved one
yesterday that allows me to find the top
players so let's look at women's
basketball and we'll look at just this
season
and get the top players so this again
will query this view player season
advanced stats and give me
the top players
in that wins above average stat so this
will take a couple seconds
again the the one of the benefits of
bigquery is that when you have really
massive data imagine you have player
tracking data or playback play something
really big it will turn through it
pretty fast and you don't have to worry
about configuration it's serverless so
the same query i'd run to process 100
rows of data can process 100 million
rows of data
it spins up what it needs to in the
background and and um it just computes
okay so we got our answer here
again this is um not necessarily the
size of the data but the complex logic
is fairly complex amongst those views
again for women's basketball this year
these are the top 10 players and ones
above average so alia boston is a very
well-known player in south carolina
who's the top team who's a top team uh
caitlyn clark really excellent player
for iowa
um can shoot from like steph curry range
amazing see this this looks pretty good
um honestly right so and ayoka lee i
think set the division one uh scoring
record earlier this year this looks
really good at least on the top of the
list i'm not a huge expert on women's
basketball but some of the names i
recognize
and um you know you can see they
contribute about five
to six wins above average at the top
so let me go back now we're gonna exit
bigquery for the moment
and
go back here to the slides
so this
we have our quote unquote final results
we have the top players
um so i looked at men's and women's
and this season and what we said we also
wanted it back to the few uh several
years so
the women's ratings like i said look
solid the going back a few years
brianna stewart sabrina yanescu really
awesome players who've gone on success
in the wnba uh kelsey plum hat i think
is the division one all-time leading
scorer these names really familiar to me
this looks solid
men's readings um again if you're not
college basketball fans this would be
meaningless to you but as those who may
be like some of these players stand out
but i'm not as familiar with the ones
from this year she boy from kentucky is
a machine rebounding so actually he
stood out some of these are a little bit
smaller schools like chattanooga
colorado state utah state
and then if you go back
frank kaminsky did win player of the
year for wisconsin so this looks
reasonable these other guys i know a
little bit but again you noticed this
small school thing
now that may be true they may be very
valuable to their teams but
um we didn't we didn't finish here right
we didn't do our
um
schedule adjustment right we just talked
about the
we we only did the framework where we
take the metrics and build
something that relates players seems to
win but we didn't do nothing we didn't
do anything where we account for who
they play and we know that some of these
players at the bigger conference schools
play harder schedules than the ones at
smaller conference schools
so what do we do
right
um so we moved to part two right this is
where we get really
um
in-depth about how to
take a thing which you know again was a
bunch of math to get here and now we
take it to the next level with sort of
statistical analysis again we'll see how
r and bigquery can help with that
so we talked about this teams face
varying levels of competition so there's
350 plus division one teams that are
organized into 32
conferences they play largely different
opponents some conferences are
traditionally better than others
also if you think about what affects
performance home court advantage matters
right so if you're playing at home a lot
you may likely do better than if you
play on the road
more and this middle section here we
have a model representation kind of what
happens so a player or a team stat
is
um
maybe
loosely related to like the intercept
sort of like a baseline
plus
maybe the team effect again plus could
be plus or minus maybe the team's above
average below average
the effect of the opponent right who
they're playing as well as maybe some
impact from home home and uh being at
home or on the road or a neutral site
and then again error right so if we
think of fitting a model like this again
very high level loose representation
um we can kind of directly measure the
effects of team versus opponent and
again home court on every stat so we use
glimnet
which is a common package um in sort of
the uh regularized regression space to
set a bridge regression range regression
helps with sort of like i said
regularization um not like
accounting for sort of outliers small
samples as well as
still giving us good estimates of these
effects and the interesting part here is
we're not fitting a model for
predictions we're fitting a model to get
coefficients that we can use
to get estimates for offensive and
defensive efficiency the effective
offensive defense efficiency on teams
and
um home court advantage as well so we're
more interested in the coefficients of
this model than any prediction at least
initially and i've like i said once i
share these slides you'll see
more details
um so that we use to adjust
offensive defense efficiency for teams
but the last thing um we are interested
in players
so once we have an adjusted team rating
what do we do for the player side well
you can see we we want to adjust at the
rating level so we can adjust players
offensive and defensive ratings
by the opponent's
ratings on the other side of the ball so
if i'm on offense my rating should be
adjusted for home court
as well as the opponent's defense and
then my defense should be adjusted for
their offense so those are the two sort
of formulas you see here they're pretty
actually straightforward once you have
these ratings the adjustments are
essentially linear combinations of this
on the game level
so a player's adjusted offensive rating
in a game might go up or down if he's at
home it'll go down uh usually about two
points or so points per hundred
possessions
and then opponent adjustment can be can
vary a lot you may play a really hard
opponent and your offense rating will
jump about 20 points or so
um again the level it's on uh points for
100 possession level so the average is
about 100 um but it also could go down
20 points or so and defensive rating you
see a little bit uh like that as well
and then once you adjust you adjust
these ratings you can aggregate those to
the season level and then follow that
same diagram we had before boom boom
boom to get adjusted when shares
adjusted winds above average and those
sorts of things
um so let's dive back into
our
r
studio instance here
[Music]
okay
sure okay
okay
so this is a different script now that
just calculates the team and player
ratings so
we use couple of the regular sort of
packages i use for doing innovation
tighter very smooth janitor we're doing
do payload processing
big r query she talked about glimnet
which is going to fit this ridge
regression and then broom which is a
nice
um package that allows you to kind of
clean up
progression outputs
um so again i'm not going to go through
we'll go through a couple sections here
this sets up for bigquery similar thing
we need to authenticate
write some helper functions this time to
download data from bigquery
we'll specify the seasons we're going to
look at so in this case the completeness
of the data is pretty solid starting
about 2013-14 so we'll start there it
gives us about nine years of data which
is what we're looking at before um
here's another thing that i do commonly
sometimes i'll write my sql with
parameters in r or python in some cases
and then
um using something like glue or format
you can then put in this the parameters
you want so if you change the seasons up
top you'll get different data
and these will sort of write the sql
so we have one for getting team data we
have a query for getting player games
data we have another query for getting
team and league stats together that's
one of the longer
skip
and then we eventually get all that data
in
um and then
we look at some metadata around the
stats we want to create
sorry i know i'm scrolling should have
looked at this a little bit better
yeah
okay one thing i wanted to show so we
eventually get to this sort of table
here where we're going to have
a table and i'll actually look at this
in the console
so we have a long table
of
um team season stats let me go one more
up actually
this is the table team game sets so we
get to this point where this is one row
per team per game per stat
so you can see that this has a game id
this is jackson state this is when they
played with dude cookman and we're
looking at their offensive efficiency
which was 118
over
60 possessions
and then um what we're going to do here
is this this is a
fairly large data set on team game level
of about 300 000 rows but we want to do
this adjustment by season we're not
adjusting this year's
jackson state team versus bethune
cookman over the last eight years we're
going to adjust it first this year so
one of the tricks here we'll go into
is
sort of this nesting concept
and what i mean by nesting is if you
look here
we then nest this team game data into
different levels by sport by season and
by stat
so there are 36 rows here
18 for men 18 for women
and 9 each within those for offensive
efficiency and defense efficiency and
one per season
and then we nest these sort of game
level stats in here and what this kind
of does is helps organize our data this
is using um tidy verse concepts per as
well so that we can fit one row one
regression per row here
um which you'll see is in the next step
so
this function again i'm i'm hoping to
share this code there's a lot of details
here i'm skipping over but what it will
do is fit that right regression we
talked about using this glimnet library
library
and then we'll use
we'll take the model coefficients kind
of pull them out
and
do a bunch of manipulations to get them
back into the right form and get team
adjusted stats off of this
what you see here is we run this using
multiprocessing with the per package
this future pmap step will basically
take each row of this say take these
games and data and give me back adjust
you take this data of games for this
season for this stat and give me back
adjusted ratings
and when you see here what you'll see is
on our next thing after we fit again i
ran this before we get adjusted
regression results so for each one of
these rows we now have regression
results and if you want to look at one
of them for example the first one
you can see it gives you two different
things we have home court advantage with
like i said an estimate about two points
and then for every team we get an
adjusted rating a couple different
versions of it
and this is the team ids
so
we move on from there we do a bunch of
stuff to then take that out extract it
put it in
and get the team team rating straight
then we want to adjust failure ratings
i'm going to again gloss over some of
this
all those calculations we did initially
in sql i can also do here in r
again i love chaining together sort of
the pipe with tight reverse
functionality
uh you can see a bunch of joining more
calculations eventually we get down to
player ratings
and i will show you this so we have this
player season summary thing
and it's pretty long but you can see it
gets season player and the last column
is that adjusted wins above average so
now we've calculated the thing we want
and then finally we will write it back
to bigquery
so
running a little short on time so not i
won't show the results in bigquery but
i'll jump back over to the slides and we
can
um at least see the results there
and
further discussion
okay
so the schedule adjusting matter this is
a question so you can see this is
actually in that thing uh in that last
script i create this plot using ggplot2
so we take for each dot here represents
the players at one player
um their raw winds above average versus
the
adjusted winds above average so there's
a very tight correlation something like
0.9 in a lot of cases here so you may
think like okay this isn't really doing
much but what you will notice is that
for each sort of like
uh vertical line which represents a win
above average there's actually a good
amount of spread amongst the adjusted
winds above average if you take a
two-win player in women's basketball
the adjusted rating might have them
close to an average player or they could
be four or five four-ish wins which is a
really big difference so we can see that
while there is a strong correlation this
does make a big difference in certain
cases and this is probably something we
do want to
account for
going forward
okay so now are more final results like
i said the top players
so a couple things to notice the top
three over here for this season women
are exactly the same but the numbers
were higher before they were closer to
five wins now they're closer to six or
seven um so all these teams are in hard
conferences so actually their schedule
was above average and therefore you get
even more credit um and you get greater
differentiation some of these top
players up here
from from the last nine years are
pushing nine or ten wins on the women's
side
um
men's ratings for this year look a
little like again she boy from
kentucky's there though you see maokai
smith
so it isn't impossible to be here if
you're in a smaller school you just have
your performance get adjusted relative
to the competition you play you face you
see some other big bigger school players
here and then the historical list as i'm
a fan of college basketball sort of
going back i think it's really
interesting you see zion who's a sort of
marquee player was an amazing player for
his one year at duke um he had the
second he won player of the year frank
convinced me one player of the year so
you see some more
more common names here so we like this
list it's pretty good
um
and i think it it does illustrate sort
of the value of the opponent adjusting
as well
all right got a few more minutes here um
loose ends so we went through analysis
we showed r we showed bigquery
um but we didn't talk about how to sort
of surface the outputs this would be
sort of the end one end game of this
process if we we had a player rating
system we really liked how would we
share it we could do it in google sheets
we could do it in a tool like data
studio which is uh google's sort of free
interactive dashboarding tool it's one
of my favorites so i think yeah it's
certainly a good way to build some stuff
it's more point and click based
looker
sort of our enterprise business
intelligence platforms um you can build
your api over the data that's much more
on the business side but it's a really
amazing tool as well and then of course
you know we're here our studio is shiny
um so shiny allows you to do a ton right
you can take the functionality of r and
build dashboards that allow you to go
deep into that data let's say you wanted
to
even run some of that adjustment code on
the fly you can do that with something
like shiny and if you build your
interactive web application there you
can publish it to something like rstudio
connect or shine uh to share within your
organization or shiny apps
publicly so again we didn't go over this
but this is sort of a large endpoint
here
um and then this is for sort of the
people coming for r on google cloud so i
showed a example of how to use r sort of
with google cloud with because we had
break query we had r removing data maybe
between the two
um that's not the same as running r or
rstudio on google cloud so here's a few
options for how to do that so our studio
workbench is sort of the professional
product the the most high-end version of
this where you can deploy our studio
directly on google cloud platform
um
but you can also do you know if you're
smaller scale you want you have access
to google cloud and you have access to
an rstudio server open source version
you can then um install it on compute
engine and then that would be similar to
what you're doing right now just on a
virtual machine somewhere
um if you're scheduling r scripts
there's ways to do that with docker
um on google cloud with a bunch of tools
like container registry
and another one this last one is one
that i actually like a lot because i'm a
jupiter notebook fan you can use
our sort of google cloud product called
vertex at workbench to run jupyter
notebooks back into my r you can
configure up your memory up and down so
again you might have some calculations
where you run out of memory you can do
that
um one other plug here mark edmondson
he's a really tremendous
google developer
expert in denmark focused on r on google
cloud he wrote some of the packages that
allow you to interface with google cloud
storage with r and a bunch of tutorials
really really helpful stuff he is an
expert in this space so i would
recommend following him and looking up
his uh website and information if you're
interested in particular about different
ways to use r on google cloud
um
this is a bunch of stuff i will
briefly go over ncaa basketball analysis
i recently did some work with mlb
partnership like i said my intent is to
share these slides you can click through
and watch and read at your leisure we
have a series on soccer data where you
can recently release or you can use
soccer data similar to this where you'll
ingest the data into bigquery you'll do
some analysis and bigquery even build an
expected goals model so that's one thing
to look out for if you're interested in
how to
use bigquery you'll see links to that in
my twitter and
linkedin as well
all right like i said i'm a little over
but let's wrap up
so
just on the tools and methods first
um
r r studio work well with bigquery
bigquery is made for very large storage
analytics so we looked at regression in
this case we did road regression so
what's interesting here is when you look
at regression you use all the hype these
days around modeling prediction
regression is really good as like a
summarization tool this is kind of how
we use it here it's not explicitly
building prediction prediction model and
i found this very useful in lots of
sports analytics tasks
there's lots of ways to do things
and like i said one you saw i did one
example where i did stuff in bigquery a
little more then i did summon r a little
more there's always trade-offs it
depends on what you want to do with the
data where maybe at the time what you're
comfortable with what your colleagues
are comfortable with so
um that's kind of a journey you go on as
a data scientist and yeah this is pretty
hard i think there's a lot here that we
went through but we got to rate all
division one men's and basketball uh
men's and women's basketball players
over nine years
with open source data r and a version of
bigquery that you could probably use um
within the free tier in terms of number
storage so that's pretty cool i think
um okay and finally my sports analytics
takeaways
so we have there's large open source
data resources i talked about the sports
dataverse shout out to syme again
allows you to do this stuff allows
anyone to kind of get started if you
have our without um doing a ton of setup
um we start we noticed how having sports
knowledge and using established work in
this field isn't really important right
so i didn't have to build a framework
from scratch about how to turn box
square stats into wins there are better
there are better more advanced ones than
the ones i use but the ones i use are
pretty well well respected and
established and we can implement them um
so again uh i heard it
i heard a quote that said like good
developers copy great developers paste
so i think the same things a lot are
applied to data scientists sometimes of
course we have to modify a bunch but it
gives us a huge head start
schedule adjustment is important
especially in college and alia boston
and oscar sheboy are really good at
basketball that's what we learned
all right
um thanks again for having me i know i
went a little over i wanted to try to
cover a bunch of things for all
different audiences here this is where
you can find me on twitter and you can
find me on linkedin
i definitely want to i think we have
some time on open up for questions
awesome thank you so much alex i always
like to say in virtual settings you
can't hear us clapping but we all are
thank you thank you so much and
i think there's so many great resources
in those slides too so
i know you'll you'll share those with us
but i can also take out all the links
and share that with the recording too
for everyone
sure
i see a few great questions coming
through on the slido and just a reminder
if anybody wants to ask questions there
either anonymously or with your name
i'll put the link
in the chat again right now
um but larry i see you had us a question
in slido um would you want to come in
live and ask that
i'd have to go thank you i'd have to go
back and look at that again um oh no
worries i can read it yeah yeah if
let me try okay and if i miss it um
because i'm distracted and this isn't my
field i work in nutrition and
it's time series of data so i'm
interested in how you evaluate the
um performance of the player year over
year or even within a year as the season
progresses
to
to say that that statistically
significant change in waa for example
yeah that's a good question um sports is
interesting in that it has a season
concept so i it actually ends up being
like
in this case it evaluates each kind of
season as its own entity and then you
can look at correlations across
this is common in sports analytics i
think if you wanted to do it as like a
time series and this would be a much
like heavier use cases you could run
this rating system every day and see how
a player's rating because it would
change not just when they play but also
based on their opponents
and then
kind of track that over time this is
something we have
done or at least my team espn had done
in the past with team ratings is you
want to see
how is the team doing day over day and
then
um if you have some sort of forecasting
model you may want to rate recent
performance more
um than later performance sometimes you
don't want to do that so i think there's
a there's a lot of interesting research
in that area
thank you
and if anyone just wants me to read
their question
no worries i can i can just read them
out as well um
but i see some people commenting in the
zoom chat as well if you wanted to ask
questions
walter would you want to jump in live
the question
was did you monetize on this or back
tests
your regression and prediction in some
way
um did i make money off this directly no
if i did i probably wouldn't tell you
about it but um so
yeah i think the the question is uh did
you so
imagine you want to use this to make
predictions
um that's a that's a good use case i
have not done that here what we're doing
here is more of a summary more of a
backward looking who was the best player
type of thing but imagine that you did
want to um it's actually the answer is
similar to the last one you can set up
this whole process to run by day
right so then you can uh have what was
the
uh zion's player rating on week one
after
um you know when he started at duke and
then a month into the season and then
all towards the end of the season and
then have that for the whole all the
players on the teams
and then use that to you know do some
game predictions um we have done that
again i've done that in the past with
team ratings run them daily and see how
they correspond
and those have done pretty well espn
college football fpi was built that way
and then eventually bpi college
basketball as well so yes in that sense
we've done that but not for this player
since though i think it would be a cool
exercise
thank you
i think danny asked a question on the
packages used so
just the question about why do you use
the big r query package instead of
bigquery r yes
it's a solid question um bigquery r is
solid as well so when i talked on one of
the last slides about mark edmondson and
he had developed a bunch of packages
for interfacing with google cloud and r
he developed bigquery r
the big r query i think was developed by
the rstudio team and and
you know maybe in consultation with
others um i haven't used bigquery r too
much i guess i started using big r query
and it has kind of met most of not all
of my needs um but there may be some
value in using
the other one i'm not i'm not saying uh
that i'd necessarily say one that's
better but like i said there's different
ways to do things they're always willing
thank you um guillerme i see you asked a
question or you said you'd like to ask a
question in the chat
you want to jump in
yes yes
first thanks to for the opportunity
rachel and alec and sorry if i
mispronunciated your names
uh
look so you created a rating for the
players based on specific stats
by doing so couldn't you for example
also create a model to predict
uh the player's values and try to sell
this information
for things
in a form for capitalizing it
just an idea
yeah um and if i release this code i
guess that will be an idea for everyone
but yeah the um
no um
so
i think this that's totally um within
realm of like what what is done in
sports analytics right so uh mitch for
example and um myself i worked for teams
and you want to have values on players
because it's really important for how
much you
who you should draft
who you should sign how much you should
pay them those sorts of things so
there's sort of the internal way and
then there's what you're talking about
which is
maybe there's a marketplace for these
ratings that people might use for
um maybe maybe like college teams can't
build these ratings themselves and they
do that so a st a site like i should
have mentioned this ken pomeroy um built
like sort of canonical college
basketball site kenpalm.com he has
player ratings on his site you can pay
for a subscription to his site people
are monetizing that um if you want to
turn this into a product right this is a
demo at this point i think the ratings
are really good i uh built some of these
for google cloud when we were doing our
ncaa partnership a couple years ago uh
you want to turn this into a product i
could see certainly teams may be paying
for it you can also see the gambling use
case where it's like you build the
ratings you don't share them but they
help you make predictions like we've
talked about a couple other questions
and then you um
kind of build that as you use the player
ratings as a way to profit that way so i
think there are
pathways i i haven't exactly pursued
them
um for this for this one
thanks for the answer and honesty
yeah thank you so much
hernan i see you have your hands on zoom
too if you want to jump in
uh yeah thank you um
so i was just wondering if you have any
specific experiences you've seen um
well first using
i guess you will call it soccer
data and um and also doing the analysis
and what has been your
uh if if you've done it would have been
specific
challenges if you will
yup so um i've used i've used soccer
data on and off for
almost 10 years now also um so
i think uh one of the major challenges
in soccer is that it's low scoring so
unlike basketball here where we can
almost do everything off of points per
possession or whatever soccer um lots of
matches and
one nil
um
no no draws pretty common right
did anyone do anything in this match so
of course they did they ran around for
90 minutes they passed the ball i tried
to do a bunch of stuff so um you know
there's been a lot of work in over over
a while now on sort of like how to
measure team and player performance
based on the actions that are taken
not just scoring goals
this expected goals framework has gotten
really popular amongst every sort of
place in soccer or you may call it
football that i know of so that is
um different ways of calculating based
on where every shot came from because
you'll have way more shots generally
then you'll have goals
assigning a value for
assigning a value for the probability
that the shot would go in and then sort
of aggregating that value so you'll you
know there's often soccer matches
because scoring so low where the best
team doesn't kind of win right uh if you
watched one team had more chances one
team had more opportunities but they
just missed them or the keeper was
really amazing um expecting goals helps
tell that story and it turns out it's
also very predictive as well from
team performance better than goals
itself in a lot of cases so that's one
thing to kind of
um to know and to keep in mind nowadays
like in every other sport there's
tracking data so you can get a lot more
information about what's going on in
soccer matches than it was you know
uh 2-1
yeah and that series i have linked in
there on bigquery does take you through
taking soccer event data and building an
expected goals model so if that's of
interest i would recommend taking a look
thanks
thank you
um one anonymous question on slido was
how do you decide what to adjust on for
example like home court advantage what
are some of the less obvious ones
yep good question um you can adjust for
a lot so
when we
at espn we're building models to predict
college football and college basketball
games the main thing to adjust for is
like again this is going backwards but
then also forwards is who you're playing
right so the opponent's gonna dictate
most home court advantage is usually the
second most
second biggest factor if you're talking
about things that are sort of
quantifiable on the game level
um but then there's other things days
rest distance traveled those were things
that we had started incorporating the
model the average if you're thinking
about this in terms of gain you're going
to get your biggest gain from the
opponent then a little more maybe from
home court and then it's
it's sort of marginal but dave's rest is
is important in some sports um
especially if there's a discrepancy
right so we
um
you know sometimes a team has a week off
another team just played
played recently so there's an advantage
there distance traveled um i think some
of my colleagues at espn have found
altitude effects right so if you look at
which
um teams have the highest home court
advantage in college and pro basketball
it's the teams that play in utah and
denver um almost always and it's because
i think the we at least suspect the
altitude the teams that are there are
used to playing there and the road teams
are
um have trouble catching their breath so
those sorts of things are interesting
you can if you get really into the
player modeling aspect then
um you open up a whole
can of adjustments you adjust for who's
on the court who's on the pitch whatever
um
in sort of these other frameworks like
adjusted plus minus which have become
popular over the years as well
cool thank you
see there's a comment on slido not
really a question but joe said i'm
excited that you've given diddy reese a
as high a ranking as you did
yeah um when we do the next one on ice
cream analytics we'll go into that but i
do love diddy reese theresa's ice cream
place near ucla
uh that i really like
great sandwiches ice cream sandwiches um
cool i see danny has your you have your
hand raised as well if you want to jump
in
yeah cheers um sorry it's another soccer
question and i'm curious about whether
you've done anything with salaries
before if you know um whether or not the
data sets
include player salaries i'm just trying
to think of
sort of
basically looking at like who's the most
efficient player like who provides the
best value
yep
um that's a great area of analysis cross
sports um there are salary data sets
available i don't know as much about
soccer
and i know it's a little bit different
because you have transfer fees and then
also like the actual player salary so um
yeah i don't know maybe someone else and
here who has a little more experience
but soccer can point to our research for
other sports there are sort of websites
that um
keep track of players salaries so
there's like hoops hype for nba there's
over the cap for nfl
um these are sort of the resources i
wonder if there's one for soccer i just
don't know about
okay i'll have a look thank you
yeah
no mitch just put one in the chat um
that is another salary site but i think
the general idea of the analysis is
really useful that's a lot of things
that like teams think about
as well
it sounds like we have a lot of soccer
fans on as well so if anyone has any
ideas for
a talk that you'd like to do on soccer
love to have that be the next sports
meetup too
i put um i did put two forms into the
chat too one is just meet up feedback if
you ever want to give suggestions or let
us know about anything and then the
other one was a meetup speaker forum if
you are interested
um nate i see you just had a question
uh in the chat as well do you want to
jump in and ask that
yeah sure um thanks for an awesome
presentation um
i'm i've been
trying to
i'd love to learn a little bit more just
about how to
make these adjustments in terms of
metrics um
for you know just for any kind of metric
i work with volleyball specifically um
and uh just being able to
you know you're
the difference between playing kentucky
versus playing
i don't know uc santa barbara is like
i'd love to learn a little bit more
about how to how to make that those
kinds of adjustments and then um
at my level uh you know playing
um one team we might be
playing their a team versus their b
teams so is it possible to to make that
adjustment at an individual level as
well
yeah um lots of good questions so
like i said we'll share some of the
resources here i
went over the how to do this schedule
adjustment here but it'll probably be
more useful to use actual code to do
that i have it um and like a little bit
more description of how to do that so
hopefully that'll
answer
the first part the second part about
adjusting at the individual level the
same team
yeah that's that's harder
because you may not have enough data on
the b team right you need
in order for this to work and it works
in college basketball because you get
eventually enough every team kind of
overlaps with every other team and you
can see generally how
um they transpire and then for the
player data that we had we're looking at
aggregates so you have players who
accrue a lot of minutes there's actually
a lot of work that you if you want to do
adjustment for how to handle the low
minutes players and usually you don't
get them their own rating and all this
stuff
um
it's like it's actually like more work
than the the regular part is just to
what to do with these like smaller
players so if you're on your own team
trying to just you kind of have like
you're a little bit data starved right
if they don't play in real matches you
won't know now you can keep track of
practice data or something about how
they're doing um in scrimmages or
something and maybe that would help but
i think it's um it's harder in those
cases where you don't collect as much
data
thank you nate and
just
you mentioning that you work with
volleyball
data as well just reminded me
of the sports analytics channel on the r
for data science
online learning community
and so i just wanted to make sure i let
people know about that too
because someone had recently posted
there about working with usa beach
volleyball teams
so let me just put the
link to join that slack in the chat
and then the channel there is just chat
dash sports analytics
and i'll put that here as well
but i also was curious if there's other
like sports communities or slack groups
or discords or things that people are a
part of as well
um yeah i'll at least answer with one so
the sports dataverse
initiative that i discussed they have a
discord group if you're interested reach
out to
simon
um so he's got a bunch of people working
on some of those packages we talked
about and
um there's a group there that chats
about different things related to that's
been i've been a recent sort of recently
joined that's been some really cool
discussions there
um and then you know we've
talked like a lot of this sports
analytics has exploded over the last
several years back in the day like
you know i knew mitch and we maybe knew
a few other people working in one sport
or the other but it's it's much bigger
than that now but in-person conferences
as hopefully as they start to come back
are really
useful for that if you can uh you know
make the time and effort
mit sloan is the big one
super expensive also so you know if if
you can get someone to pay for it great
you should go
um but there's also
many great smaller analytics conferences
some with virtual components too
kind of across the us and abroad too so
i'd look out to that or build your
network see see what things people are
working on if you can't attend the
conference maybe watch some of the
videos afterwards ton ton of resources
certainly relative to
several years ago
awesome
if other people have
tips or community resources to share
please feel free to put them in the chat
too or jump in
i will put a little plug for we just
announced to save the date for the
rstudio conference as well
um so
we're so excited to be able to meet in
person again so that will be july 25th
through the 28th in dc
and i know at those we've had like birds
of a feather for different industry
groups as well and i'm sure sports
analytics will be one of those
walter i see you asked one other
question too
and i can read it for you
it was do you know if tracking data is
also an option or available for
basketball games
um
and then just said great talk thanks for
organizing
yeah uh thanks so do tracking data
is hard to come by publicly um
so
let's see the good news the nfl has
released tracking data for the last
several years as part of the big data
bowl which was the subject of the last
sports analytics meetup i think that we
had we had tom from the nfl talking
about it and
um they just announced their winners
today actually
so
that is cool for football american
football tracking data basketball
tracking data i haven't seen
um released publicly i think what nba
training data was available for a while
um but then was not made available um
the thing you know maybe the league or
someone will come up with that you can
also look for
places like stats perform is a company
that collects this type of data
sometimes they release it for research
purposes
or they might have a hackathon where
you'll get access to data for some point
i would love to see more publicly
available tracking data
like i said the big data ball is like
the best initiative i've seen around
that there may be others that i'm uh
there's some soccer tracking data
available too actually um publicly but
there isn't a ton and not that i know it
for basketball
uh maybe derived from image recognition
yes
so um there's a really great talk from
neil johnson at
mit sloan conference and others probably
two years ago about how to do this using
open source tools i am not a computer
vision expert but definitely could do
uh your next project that maybe your
next project
a question i had and i'm not even sure
if i'm framing this the right way but
as you think about like what to
um consider as you like adjust your
models or address the ratings
are there sometimes things that like
come up that
like
athletes decide is the wrong thing for
us to be adjusting based on versus what
somebody thinks
like one person thinks and then might
sell that data
um
and like are there ethical
considerations around that
there's definitely considerations um
around what you might do how you might
model things
um
so
i would say like there's often pushback
from
[Music]
those sort of in the industry or around
ratings like this for many reasons right
um and so i said we argue about the
ratings that's like that's the last step
of every rating system so we um
the the thing to keep in mind as like
you you as the analysts um
you should know the limits of what
you're doing but also like
the benefits of what you're doing so
your system is not going to take
everything a player does it's not
comprehensive etc doesn't necessarily
know about their motivation though it
may capture some of that based on how
they play
so um you don't necessarily you want to
take that to the coach these are the
best players let's go one two three five
or whatever
it's one area and then also listen about
how they think about these things and um
you know also study your statistics
which trends year over year you know
here i just measured
stuff i didn't say like does this
correlate really strongly year over year
or things like that those are really
good analyses to do
um and then if you're ever going to like
present a player something you know be
careful how would you like it if someone
evaluated you based on every single
action you took in our studio and
the bigquery console for example i
wouldn't like that so just think about
that and uh yeah often you don't
necessarily directly present the players
but they they do uh you put these
ratings out and someone you know we've
had nfl quarterbacks complain about nfl
qbr
um
to directly or indirectly when we
release that at espn so being ready for
criticism is so if you get if you go big
then you should know you should think
about that definitely it's interesting
i uh i want to make sure i didn't miss
anybody's question um from either the
chat or anything i've missed in slido so
feel free to jump in or raise your hand
here if there's any other questions
thank you so much alec for an awesome
presentation and for staying on and
answering all the questions too
really appreciate it
yeah thanks much for having me um rachel
mentioned in our studio like i said big
fan so glad to do this uh everyone else
feel free to reach out like i said the
ways i just did happy to answer
questions
awesome i also um just wanted to let
people know too if you are trying to
figure out like when these events are
different meetups too
we did create a community calendar that
you can use i just put into the chat
there
and so you could either add the whole
calendar but beware that adds everything
to your own calendar or you can add the
individual
events below
so if that's helpful for anybody i know
sometimes i'm all over the place with
where i'm posting everything
so just wanted to share that there too
but thank you all so much for joining
thank you so much alec and mitch for
helping to plan it too have a great rest
of the day everyone
[Music]
you